Novak Djokovic went from growing up in
Serbia finding his passion for tennis
when he was just four years old to
becoming one of the greatest tennis
players of all time at the time of this
filming he has won 14 Grand Slam singles
titles and is the first person since
1969 to hold all four major titles at
the same time he's a big believer in the
power of meditation and has been known
to meditate for up to an hour a day at
the Buddhist temple in Wimbledon the
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend here's my take and
Novak Djokovic is top 10 rules for
success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one dream big
Belgrade as many cities around Serbia
has suffered a lot because of war many
people have had
or tomorrow brings they were not
certainly they are able to support their
children and in this particular
situation were my parents too
knowing what we have been through
actually strengthened my my character I
used to run around outside of our
restaurant and very nearby something was
going on some kind of construction I
asked the workers and then they told me
that they're building tennis courts I
never heard the word tennis
I knew football and some other sports
but tennis was absolutely new to me into
my family fell in love instantly with
the sport I used to play for hours
against the wall
on the television I watched Pete Sampras
play for his first win
I decided to dream big and dream about
being one day and the center called
Wimbledon holding them trophy
rule number two have a winning mindset
something you said that you you're
reaching your peak do you think though
you can still take it to another level
or do you think this is as good as it's
going to get for you well I like to use
one quote that the limitations exist
only in our minds and if you start using
imaginations then your your
possibilities become limitless so that's
that's kind of a mindset that I have I
use my imagination I do see myself
achieving more I'm hoping I'm working
hard on it not only myself but the
entire team around me rule number three
believe it's incredible how the
excitement is rising as you approach any
Grand Slam and especially for me here in
Para is the one that I didn't win it's
completely different feeling coming to
Paris and preparing for our girls than
any other event really not in terms of
pressure and expectations but just in
terms of excitement and getting on the
court competing and trying to see how
far I can get
but that's something I look forward to
really I mean I've been building
building up and winning a lot of matches
and putting putting myself in really
position that maybe I never had before
probably you know prior to wrong era so
you know hopefully this is the year I
don't I don't I can't guarantee anything
I can't predict anything I can't say how
the tournament is gonna go but I'm gonna
try to get my you know give myself
[Music]
reason to believe I can make it through
an everyday commitment discipline and
things that I can influence rule number
four appreciate what you have
I appreciate things in life and I value
everything I have much more because of
the paths that I had Serbia is a small
country of course very small comparing
to the United States and we had a tough
past especially in the last three
decades we had two wars we had a
sanctions embargo for ten years people
had to wait in a line for bread and milk
and it was it was tough I've been
through all of that with my with my
grandparents with my parents there were
times when I was not able to travel for
the tournaments in junior circuit
because we didn't have the possibility
financial possibilities but you know
when I look back I'm happy that I had
the past like this because as I said in
the beginning and made me appreciate
everything I have now were you and your
family in physical danger when you were
a kid yes yes we were well you know I
think most people would agree that war
is something that that you know it
doesn't bring any good to anybody nobody
wins in the war so I don't wish anybody
to experience what I and my family or
many people serving people have
experienced you know you see the planes
flying over your head and you know bombs
and people you know people running away
crying the building's burning you know
and so forth so it's it's it was really
tough you were of course worried for
your survival what what the next day
brings but most importantly we stayed
together as people and his family and
you know it made us stronger you know
that never leaves you does it you always
have that in you that experience that
you live through yes yes I do and
actually has been a big part of my you
know mental strength and and you know
ability to to kind of cope with with big
moments in my tennis career and with the
pressure and expectations and so forth
and you are able to hang on to that
perspective a lot of times things like
that that are life-changing one things
would would be automatic but sometimes
they drift away but you you are able to
hang on to that each and every every day
of your life of course there are some
memories that that you know I would not
like to have you know her again but you
know their images that they stick in
your mind for all of your life but you
you you can never ask people to forget
but they can forgive and move on and I
think you can always learn from the
experience try to understand what you
know what your purpose is and and why
that has happened and
of course you always be positive rule
number five have realistic doors my
lifelong ambition is to become number
one in the world developed in assemblies
and I know that I'm relatively close to
achieving this goal with pomp or
Gladiator
but I don't want to put any pressure on
myself with regards to this it's
important to remember that I'm only 21
and there are not many players who have
become number one in the world at this
age I simply wouldn't be realistic in my
goals at the moment there are two
players in front of me do are better
than me I'll do all I can to improve by
at least one position in the forthcoming
year so got pregnant but I can't say for
definite that this will happen we'll
just have to wait and see Shalini
Desna will number six always keep
growing I believe each season is
bringing some new challenges and
allowing you to grow in many levels so I
feel like today I'm a more matured as a
person I've grown I've improved I've
learned how to deal with my emotions
better and just overall a stronger
player physically and mentally as well
so I'm trying to you know incorporate
all these experiences and things that
made me made me stronger and made me who
I am today and of course keep the right
path going rule number seven have a
holistic approach to life I think it was
Rafa who said that you're having one of
the most memorable seasons in the
history of the sport so what are you
doing differently this year well I've
been I've been trying to obviously
respect the same kind of regime of
training and kind of a lifestyle and
dedication and professionalism to a
sport that I've had over the course of
last five six years and he's been
working really well I think I just
managed to reach at this time of my
career in my life a peak of my abilities
mental emotional and physical so
everything kind of came together and
so I'm a more experienced player I know
how to handle pressure on and off the
court so III approach to tennis life
very holistically and I try to cover
every aspect of my life and and my being
in order to to reach that height rule
number eight overcome obstacles if you
see the football players when they win a
big title Champions League for example a
lot of them they fall to the ground yeah
it's just that there's so so many
emotions going through your mind through
your body undoubtedly there is a huge
pressure and expectations and and the
importance of that moment and you're
aware of that you know you can't put it
aside and say okay I'm gonna ignore it
no it becomes a part of you it consumes
you now it's it's it's on you if you if
you are able to if you are able to
overcome that obstacle to face that I
would say big sensation of mix of doubts
fears excitement you know pressure or so
forth and if you are able to become one
with it and then then it allows you to
get to where you want to be rule number
nine chase your dreams
evil information for an opportunity
$1
the protein it's a new technique of a
ticket or a permanent good not to pry
off airplane dabra dabra dabra cheapest
the training got easier to see how much
dough you can is a variable but thing is
already elbows started Teutons till you
tell me the first a product and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is have fun i hope
i'll be able to decrease my unforced
error that comparing to the match that
I've had today and hopefully I'll be
able to do that and you know perform my
best and better
well congratulations are in order not
only for winning this match
sorry everybody's laughing I just want
to hear what do you say I'm sorry sorry
sorry please be quiet
what did you say okay thanks buddy
no more drop shots Oh
I hate to say that but you are
absolutely right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I don't do any of those things anymore
none of those I don't stick my ass out
anymore okay I don't I don't do this
with my I don't do this with my hair
anymore so obviously you haven't watched
me play resign
all right you think it's possible are
you sure about this one I'm ready
we go again wig
give me a best shot
rubén ramírez scenario for the other
and you rally
coming back about three years
[Music]
I guess it only takes six total matches
since about me in Berlin
[Music]
I said it was hot or water started in
lomatin she like didn't help her back
much Lawson next week in LA or first
match to Sun hair
you have set up Ola family in 3d to set
up around as much as you can yes you're
not gonna probably order people sleeping
is
Roger Federer career record at the US
Open 41 a of course to 1997 champion
from 6 to 17
we
[Music]
Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
this la viga
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people your passion can change the way
people not one drop of myself work
depends on your it's supposed to mean
if you like this video check out the top
10 I did on Roger Federer the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
the moment I left the the tennis courts
me I try to forget what I just did on
the tennis court for at least a moment